you
hi everyone is Jerry this is game 2 from
the 1971 candidates match between Tigran
Petrosian and Bobby Fischer Petrosian
had white in this game and opened with
d4 and Fischer elects on move 3 d5 the
groom fell defense trojan now plays
Bishop f4 getting the queenside pieces
out first could also view this as making
sure you get your bishop outside of your
eventual pawn chain or even avoiding a
particular pawn structure do you know
that if you capture on d5 as white you
need to be content with this pawn
configuration and if it's something
you're not comfortable with you can take
a page out of petrosian's book and
simply develop Bishop g7 III and
outcomes c5 welcoming a lot of exchanges
welcoming the opening up of the position
and what exactly might prompt such a
move well let's look at the king
positions it takes white a few moves
before he can be castled whereas black
just one and so maybe there's a way to
take advantage of this maybe there's a
way to exploit some pin on the c3 Knight
do know that with III being played there
is no return of this dark square bishop
and so maybe there's a way to be putting
some pressure on the dark squares on the
Queen side on the White Queen side this
quadrant of the board we do see that
after D take C Queen a5 comes and this
has some pressure on it and not long
after there can be three pieces hitting
that Square both the knight and Bishop
in just a single move so that is
addressed rook C one comes ninety four
follows and we have yet another pawn
grab allowing Knight takes Knight
because we have a sneaky reply we don't
have to immediately recapture in fact
that's simply bad our King has to run
scared so we don't want to do that and
instead we place the knight in a counter
pin Queen grabs upon we recapture on c3
and now she drops back to put pressure
on
five Bishop c4 proceeding with
development there's not a better
diagonal playing to e2 you're staring
into space
d3 you're staring at a rock and why not
play to c4 might as well anticipate
black being castled and it's usually not
a bad idea to be opposite your
opponent's King Knight d7 you're not as
black going to just recapture the pun
you didn't give that pawn up just to
simply recapture it he also has black
need to focus on development and Knight
d7 does just that and at least you give
white something to think about maybe
it'll be the Queen maybe it'll be the
knight maybe the knight will go
elsewhere we do see that in this game
this is the typical by the way this is
the typical piling up I don't know if
you'd call it a principal or not but
it's it's a common idea you could there
are many times where you can simply
recapture a pond or a piece something
that is fairly static it's not going to
run away on you maybe it's a better idea
to not recapture but rather pile up on
that pond right now it's hit twice it's
defended zero unlikely the case that
white can make on their next move a move
that would defend this pawn twice so we
have 90 to 95 is played so we're not
capturing on c5 just yet the idea behind
this is to eventually pick up the bishop
pair it hits the bishop it kicks them
back to a2 and it also does one more
thing as a close eye on d3 and it is ID
yet again with Bishop f5 you really
can't deal with the knight jumping in to
d3 so he needs to be taken out it should
takes Bishop takes and now black has the
bishop pair but that short-lived Knight
d4 comes counter-attack against the
bishop and also looking to remind black
that this extra pawn could turn out to
be a passed pawn in a great pain on the
black side so in other words if the
bishop runs away well this is not a good
road to go down as black so black gives
this bishop up grabs on c5 gives the
bishop and now we have some issue here
for the black side
we have some problem with the black king
where is his safe home it's a good
question that I simply don't have a good
answer to I'm not sure if he's safer on
e8 f8 or after having castled I don't
know if he's better on g8 the move
played here is Queen a5 after white
completes development the move played
here is Queen a5 another move to maybe
look into is a5 this is a passed pawn
not that it's it's really going to come
to a great halt once it gets to a three
it's going to be difficult to dislodge
this Bishop but maybe the other idea
behind this is to have some type of a
rook lift one one idea might have been
by white to play something like f4 for
example if black castles in this
position maybe it's to eventually play
something like f4 with tempo and have
this type of a rook lift them but you
know if a5 is played maybe there is some
way to have some defense and lateral
defense with this Queen side rook it's
tough to say
Queen a5 is the move that is played in
this game Queen a2 can't really defend
f5 so this pond is moved f4 is played
and c4 these pawns get rolling and the
idea here keep in mind with opposite
color bishops is to make sure that your
bishop is active otherwise it's it's
it's almost like you're playing down a
piece and so this pawn is looking to get
up to c5 so that d6 can be played
successfully and so that the bishop will
have direct sight of a square
immediately or right next to the
opposing king so that's what we have we
have c4 we white simply ignore that
tension playing c4 Fischer captures on
e3 and it's almost like white is just
not paying any attention to these black
moves allowing this pawn to advance to
capture and white is just pushing
forward well keep in mind it's difficult
to even find a good home for the black
king and this is going to be a very
serious threat soon enough with ideas of
converging on f7 in some way with the
queen and the bishop maybe getting on
this diagonal so Queen to d2 offering
the Queen exchange we definitely decline
that we have the safer King so let's
keep the most powerful piece around that
comes with check the King plays to f8
and now comes rook d1 Queen e2 and with
the d6 there's a great amount of
calculation or a decent amount of
calculation with this move because black
can be winning some material but
material isn't really that big a deal
when we are trying to attack the King
and that's exactly what white is going
for in this game the bishop is bearing
right down at that King position the
Queen is not long off from forming a
battery on that diagonal and this F file
can be peeled open at any moment so what
am I talking about exactly what type of
calculation was needed
when Petrosian played d6 well keep in
mind after now Queen h5 there's two
things going on a primary one there's a
maid threat on h2 and B now that e 2 has
been vacated the move e 2 is a threat
forking both rooks so we need to save
our King f4 is played e 2 is played we
grab the bishop this F file is now
opened a takes d promoting to new queen
we recapture and now well black is up
material but what exactly are these two
rooks doing nothing in fact in this
whole game which is close to ending they
simply won't move at all Queen take C
Rick comes back over and it's very
difficult they're simply not a good
defense for black there's just too much
pressure there's three pieces attacking
and you may also view this pawn as being
an attacking force on this d6 square
ready to capture on e7 and disrupt the
black King position they're simply not a
defense for black at this point so if
what is tried is f6 Queen b3 focusing on
this diagonal and making sure that the
Queen is functioning as a queen and what
I mean by that is because what I mean by
that is that you can very well play to
c4 and I think you would maybe be
viewing the Queen as just a bishop alone
she's focusing on just that f7 square
but keep in mind by playing to b3
there is also an idea of grabbing a b7
and so if e 6 is played you can grab on
b7 and you can stop the Queen from
getting here but look at this all these
ponds they start rolling the bishop is
right into play all of the white pieces
are working and well you can't grab this
pawn either due to a mate in one and
then - so in other words make sure when
you make your Queen moves you are really
having or be a true Queen I guess you
could say not just functional not just
functioning as a rook so a couple
different directions here and there's
again no defense black tries to run the
Queen sneaks in pawn takes now we have
ideas of the rook crashing through black
is going to have to give up the Queen at
this point but we never really get to
see that much after the check King h1 it
is at this point that Fischer simply
throws in the towel there's no defense
to moves like rook to f6 Queen g7 or
even the direct rook to h5 check for
example give a check on a1 white is
there to block again at the end of the
day your end up having to give up the
Queen if she drops back here you can
always give this check and she'd have to
block or just take the rook this is
simply game over black is going to be
lost however you slice it so just a very
quick recap of this game again we had
the grünfeld defense we had black trying
to exploit the fact that the white king
needed a few moves before he was Castle
the other idea here being to let's say
not recapture on this square right away
instead piling up this piling up idea
and when we have a safer King in this
position right here as soon as there was
this damaged structure as soon as we
have a safer King we are not so welcome
to having the Queen's being exchanged so
we avoid that and with these opposite
color bishops what do we want to do we
want to make sure that we can get it
activated and we saw that with these
particular pawn advances the bishop is
now they're hitting at f7 directly and
certainly some calculation needed that
this d6 with this d6 move queen h5
dual-threat but material not so much a
factor when we are looking to attack the
opposing King and it was simply too much
for black to bear in this one after move
32 King to h1 again it is at this point
that Fischer resigned so that's all for
this video as always I hope you got
something out of it take care bye
you